having her children try and learn on an
empty stomach is one of this Mother's
greatest burdens
crowded together in their home in a slum
in South Delhi
she scrapes together what little she can
to keep her family fed
baby Devi is a domestic worker earning
fifty dollars a month
she applied for a ration card two years
ago but she's one of nearly three
hundred thousand applicants who haven't
heard back
if we start getting rations we'll be
able to save some money my children will
be able to eat properly they'll be able
to continue to study this is the
difficulty that we Face we need a ration
so that my kids do not sleep hungry you
can see the impact of inflation
food rations are issued using figures
last updated in 2011.
this activist says the Indian
government's policy to tackle this
problem won't be effective unless the
true population size is known the only
way the number of ration cards can be
enhanced
under the national food Security Act the
quota can be enhanced is if a census is
taking place if the census doesn't take
place there is no way that even if
States collect
lists and names of people there is no
way that they can actually issue ration
cards under the national food Security
Act
70 percent of Indians or 813 million
people are meant to receive a food
subsidy allocated to different states on
a quota basis
as the NGO population Foundation of
India points out it's a quota that
simply hasn't kept pace with the numbers
selecting the beneficiaries for a range
of schemes is done on the basis of
census and if you don't have sensors
your planning can go wrong your budget
allocations can go wrong but most
importantly people who deserve and need
the social services
do not add many are likely to not be
included in the net for Devi it's an
unsure future she tries to raise the
next Generation on an empty belly
Michael Apple Al Jazeera